the following
is a presentation of the st louis chess
club
you're live hello everyone i'm grand
master
dennis borosch and we're back with
our podcast show where we talk with
prominent personalities and chess
streamers
our today's guest is a unique one
some call him the bob ross of chess
others which is more of like
a self-proclaimed name a pawn grubber
i'm pleased to introduce you yasser
saravan
good to have you a pleasure to be with
you hello everyone
i got roped into this because it just so
happened
that the grand chess tour started from
st louis
and we were doing commentary until
the bucharest tournament ended and
well you know nature bores a vacuum
and since we have a few days before the
paris
grand chester started
explains why i'm here nice to be with
you yeah
so just introducing this show
usually we talk about careers stories
sometimes streams but as a chess
personality
you have a bigger track record playing
champions
yes and not the viewers i was pretty
sure you played viewers
oh yes no i've hosted a couple of
streams in my time for sure
just a quick brief background i'll try
to make it as brief as i can
i started chess in 1972. i was caught up
in the whole bobby fischer boom
against boris baskey my family had moved
from virginia beach virginia
to seattle washington in the summer of
72
and the whole world seemed to be chess
minded and uh growing up in seattle
we say in seattle we don't tan we rust
you know yeah we play a lot indoors
and uh chess was like perfectly at the
time
again i was 12 and uh bobby fischer
was this rather larger than life
character
and i learned the game of chess and i
was very very fortunate i
i fell into a group of chess friends
all who were older than i and
we just absolutely adored bug house
what we called siamese chests in the
northwest chest
siamese chest which makes more sense
than bug house yeah
i don't know we don't even call it bug
house in any other country
exactly exactly so siamese chess and
uh that was just so much fun playing
as a member of a team i was getting
killed of course because i was
just very very very weak i was a
beginning player
but it really uh bit
my imagination if you will and i started
playing chess and
like somehow in
i want to say the winter of 72 is
like my first tournament and i started
with three losses
it was one of those weekend swiss
tournaments where you play three games
on saturday two games on
friday today it's on sunday pardon me
today it's just hard for me to imagine
how could i play three days
one day right like it's crazy
so i lose the i lose my three games on
saturday and i win the two games on
sunday which was pretty cool right
my first tournament games and i won a
trophy
which was for the best player
under 16 years of age not bad
that's pretty good much later i was
to discover that i was the only lawyer
under 16 years of age
and regardless of how i had done i was
going to get the trophy
anyway i uh i got the trophy
and uh i come home
and my family's all in the kitchen
because you know like that's the place
to go you know like
that's where the food is you know so
everybody's milling around and they're
all whispering to themselves because
they know
i lost my first three games and uh
and how did he do what's he looking like
is he is he happy so i got the trophy
behind my back and i walk
through the doorway and right above the
doorway we have these one of those cheap
plastic clocks you know you always look
at it and you see the tires
it goes tick tock tick no it doesn't die
no
no no no it was somehow somehow it was a
silent
one yeah it was really really nicely
silent
so i walk through and
the clock exactly at that moment decides
to fall down hit
me on the head falls to the ground and
shatters breaks
and everybody laughs because my mother
says oh my god he must have won
his ego so big he can't get through the
door
he was just rather insightful i mean i
still don't understand how the clock
fell
this feels like a union story like the
timing was just right
for the moment it's terrible it's
terrible and that was
my kind of my start in the world of
chess i got a 1200 maybe it was
1100 northwest chess rating my first
rating and i'm sure i was way
way overrated at that um
i think the two players i played on
sunday must have been exhausted
from their saturday games anyway what
was remarkable and i really mean to say
i was proud of it at the time now i
don't even talk about it
not at all i got
my third and final grandmaster norm
at the age of 19 wow that's
very fast 10
months 19 years and 10 months
which was something like seven years
after i was introduced to the game of
chess so in seven years
yeah and you know in those days it
wasn't like you had
google you have much less tournaments in
those times right oh yes
oh yes now you just click and you're in
a tournament exactly it's
that time how often did you have a
tournament no no no no
no no no no grand master norms were just
like never never
you just never got them it was just i
played like one
tournament in um
the louis statham tournament in lone
pine
california uh those were the norm
tournaments maybe there was a new york
open i i but it was
very very very very rare anyway the
point was
was that i couldn't do a google search
and find out
who was the youngest we all knew the
youngest like that was a joke you're not
even going to talk about bobby fischer
because that record
would never ever ever be broken a
grandmaster of 15 come on
i mean it's it's absurd yeah it's
absolutely totally totally absurd
so i was a grandmaster at like 19
months 19 years and 10 months and i
decided to look it up but again you
couldn't do a google search it wasn't
like
there was you know go to the 2700.com
and find out
yeah so it was really really hard but i
i broke it down and i discovered much to
my surprise that
at the time that bobby fischer got his
grandmaster title
the youngest previous to him was a
gentleman by the name of boris baskey
so spassky had been the youngest grand
master ever until bobby fisher came
along
yeah and that kind of rings a belt
because there is like a
famous game between korchnoy and spassky
uh in the living fish where like um
spasky blunders away a piece okay and
uh he was like 16 then and right of
course
you'll never be anybody and
then he mends up so to say i guess
that's what gorsner would use
yeah and i guess that that becomes the
grand master
right the third youngest grand
master after fisher after spassky
was a very unique individual from brazil
his name was henrikh mkhitaryan oh mack
king yeah
king he was the greatest player to come
out of south america
if you don't think about it and you're
probably the most religious yeah exactly
to that point in the 70s and 80s and
number four
was moi ah so i was like hey man
that's like they're doing pretty good
around the world how did you get the
information
i really had to rely upon friends like
john donaldson
and this is researcher supreme like yes
like john is just amazing
well known for that even today and there
were people at the uscf that had some
kind of
records i'm not talking about rpad elo
i'm just mean
um uh the ratings directors and stuff
like that i
i i managed okay and so there i was
thinking it was really good
and now today you know like they're
breaking they're trying to break
carjackings right uh the record
at 12 years like like who knew that
judith was going to beat bobby's record
in so many
bobby's record but it was a completely
different time because again
like when i played in these tournaments
to get grand masters
norms they simply weren't possible and
it was only like when i started going
into europe and playing in round robin
events and doing some things like that
that i got it but anyway so that was
kind of a brief history i became a grand
master
encouraged media propelled me onwards it
was like the strangest thing
it was a kind of a catch-22 i wanted to
become a grandmaster
great but organizers were only
interested in inviting you if you were a
grandmaster ah
yes or if you had like a super high
rating
so but so like well like how
how do i become a grand master if i
don't have the norm
if you don't mind asking
so you played in the world junior
championships and i'm
wondering in 1979 how
important that was it was absolutely
vital
so in 1978 it was my first outing
uh in graz uh austria my first outing in
the u.s in the world junior championship
i got crushed i mean there were
artur use of pop and all of these
it was great i i was playing in front of
my u.s
flag and there was the soviet flag and
i'm like
looking i'm supposed to be the angel and
my opponent's supposed to be the devil
he's a really nice guy
he played football on the off day it's
like what what what
my first fourier into international
events
and the world junior championship was a
disaster
well for me i had high expectations
i didn't fulfill them a year later i was
back
and i went to norway norway
and uh the the most like this was like a
tournament
one of those strangest incredible
amazing events
ever uh we actually played
uh the organizer was a fellow by the
name of arnold eichrem
and mr eichram arnold
well arnie he was the mr norway i mean
if it wasn't for
arnie arcrum there would be no norwegian
chess none
the guy did everything and he organized
events he sponsored events
he got people to come to those events
including
we played at a women's college women's
university that was supposed to be
empty but it wasn't it wasn't
it was like a lot of the ladies who were
studying at the college
at the university you know stayed on
over for their summer semester or
whatever
and here we were like a group of like a
hundred junior players from around the
world
being tormented
[Laughter]
by these norwegian collegiate girls who
would literally
that we had to walk up the stairs and it
was like
walking through you know like we'd be
grabbed and groped
as we were saying it was amazing all
that hazing
i know i tell you it was rough i tell
you i mean
my goodness uh today there's this
politically incorrect type
yeah that is very politically correct
behavior
terribly amazing thing happened 10 and a
half out of 13
i was the gold medal winner ahead of
yusupov
dulmatov you you supposed churning sorry
and predrag nicholas and a number of
other shannon was
unrated he has no rating now of course
if you know he is a coach a well-known
coach i think coach
fabiano yes and also part of team
kasparov
yeah many many players and
literally today
if you win the world junior champion
it's not a norm
they give you the title yeah okay in
those days
i it wasn't a norm that wasn't one of my
norms
but thanks to winning the world junior
championship
i got an invitation to buy gonzaga oh
so it was actually a ticket absolutely
absolutely and that world junior
championship
i was on sabbatical i was like i had
graduated a year early from
high school with the intention of going
to the university of washington
in seattle and i still remember i filled
out the
form and i was doing all the things that
i was supposed to do
and 2 570
was going to be tuition for
the trimester two thousand five hundred
and seventy dollars pardon me
two thousand five hundred seventy
dollars and some run
somewhere i'm writing out the forum
you know i get an inspiration it comes
into my mind i don't know
why i say to the man
by the way i am the champion of
washington state in chess
he said really yeah
the champion of washington he didn't
react in that kind of positive manner
that i really wanted
so i had to emphasize the point for all
ages
i am the best chess player in the whole
of washington state
he said that's amazing i didn't know
that in two thousand five hundred and
seventy dollars
now now it's like my gosh
you know webster university and other
universities really were the pioneers
but you can get full scholarships to go
and play
in university chess competitions
in my day it didn't
get you a five percent discount you know
not even a family discount
it was pretty bad i mean that's why
fisher is
so important because he said no
value as players
and yeah talk about fisher for a second
please um when
you were growing up and got interested
in chess did you
recall the games you looked at do you
remember like the
bishop sacrifice or did you look at that
at the time
yeah i did i i followed it and then of
course much later
like the 60 memorable games kind of
became a bit of a bible for me i mean
i got a copy this copy looks so chewed
up it looks like a dog
you know like it's it's marked up
everything everything looked like
i dropped it in the bathtub and i must
have read it in the bath and
anyway it's a really really messed up
copy of 60 memorable games but it was
one of those books
very much like michael tall's 1960 world
championship matchbook
where i read it as maybe a class player
some interesting insights from it read
it as
maybe an expert i thought i was reading
it for the first time
like wow this is just an amazing book
and like it's
full of all of this chess knowledge that
was extraordinary to me then i read it
maybe as
a chess master 2200 and i was reading it
for the first time in other words i read
the book five
six seven times at various moments in my
life and each time seemed to have felt
like i've learned more from it now than
i ever did before
so it was like again for me that book by
michael tall
is 1960 world championship matchbook
is the greatest book ever at full stop
end of story and 60 memorable games is
right there is number two
and those two books can be read
and you learn you pick up so much as you
get better and better it's pretty
it was an extraordinary phenomena bobby
fischer
like for me i think i was born at the
best of times and at the worst of times
in the sense that i joined this bobby
fischer parade
and i was going places and doing
wonderful things and
becoming a chess grand master and
it is impossible to explain
what bobby's position in the world of
chess was his significance was
greater than let's say a kind of a
combination of magnus carlsen
and gary kasparov combined and for an
american audience
uh it was through the roof so there i
was
joining this great parade of would-be
players and would be stars and we were
going to conquer the world we're going
to be the great
the next great sportsman mind
masters we're going to be called the
mind masters
we're going to take over the world and
we're all going to become
multi-millionaires forget about the nba
forget about the nfl forget about golf
and tennis
chess is going to be the big deal to be
the big deal because all kachilians and
kajillions of dollars so
it wasn't just me i mean there were
others nick de fermi and
john fedorowitz larry christensen you
can just go on
the list of names of people within my
age benjamin joel benjamin
and we were all deeply inspired
three years later in 1975 after three
years after winning the world chess
championship bobby doesn't play a single
game of chess
at all and like disappears
you yeah all imagine marching down main
street
you know for the parade and suddenly the
parade and the band leaders are just
amazing you know like what are we doing
and in the 70s in those years of the 70s
and the early 80s
like the world of chess was rife
with rumors what was bobby doing he was
preparing to
beat anatoly karpov he was he was doing
this he was doing that
he had refused a million dollars from
volkswagen he had refused a million
dollars in commercial advertisement
from johnson and johnson shampoo and he
had done these things and those things
and he refused
all of this money and we were all
confused so it was like
the best of time and the worst of time
you know
and he had played that match in 1975
against bob against uh anatoly karpov
and peggy parton
so it would have been just a totally
different world yeah and it's
interesting because
in some ways we have a similar time
we've got the queen's gambit
some online boom happening brilliant
it's wonderful
marvelous twitch everything youtube
exclusively
i encourage it i do think that it
does rhyme to that fisher era boom yeah
well again uh the
queen's gambit this kind of fictitious
series yeah that became very popular is
popul help popularized chess but
there's no way you can take this
kind of fictitious series uh
and you know compare it to you know the
real
thing so in other words imagine
that star wars this wonderful creation
from george lucas
captures the world's imagination and on
the
day that star wars is released superman
appears
i mean a genuine real superman
you know like star wars is not as
important as superman
superman you can touch and feel superman
and that
you know like i was very very very
fortunate because
a lot of people ask me who's your
favorite player
or who's the best player of all time
who's the strongest player of all time
and i'm sitting there saying well i
don't know what your list is but my list
would be something like gary kasparov
anatoly karpov bobby fischer
magnus is definitely getting up there
this one-a-thon or not
now i don't know if those guys are on
your top 10 but it's kind of hard to see
why not those guys are amazing well
guess what
i mean i've been around and i've watched
them develop
and i played with them like with the
exception of bobby fischer of course
but for me you know like gary kasparov
was just this
giant of a chess player magnus and
karpov
and they had their eras and fisher was
something special
although we were two ships we kind of
passed i did get a chance to meet bobby
fischer
speak with him uh play chess or rather
analyze with bobby fischer
but uh at that point he was really
he was out there one foot out the door
one foot
as far as being a chess player it was
like he's making this
it was very strange at the later stages
of his life in 1992
it's betty stefan where i met i met and
spoke with
him uh the rematch uh
with uh for spanish i wrote a book about
that by the way called no regrets
and the book is available on ebay for
like eighteen hundred bucks
i'm not kidding you could like you could
like look it up it's like it's like a
joke
it's like we have a hilarious in the
chat about no regrets
someone really wants that is there any
chance you'll be able to put it back
into print
no
no way no way no it's just so much too
fun it's just too much fun
but how about podcasts like i'm what i'm
usually curious about because a lot of
times
people used to read books but recently
but recently everyone is into
listening to podcasts and stuff like
that
do you consider creating podcasts and
such well for me myself as a host of a
podcast
meaning just reading up your book
and give it as a way as a product
i have it no the answer to your question
dennis would be no but i've recently
it was a very strange period for i think
everybody this last year the last 15
months
um but i recently did like an audio book
yes yeah
yeah a chessable chessable courses so i
had the
the sicili the series of books the play
woody chess series
and i converted them to a video and
audio experience
along with um i want to call it the move
trainer experience
where you're asked questions at a
certain moment
to test your comprehension of the
material that's being presented and i
had a lot of fun
doing uh the conversion to the chessable
and it's
it's a bit like an audio book it's like
i'm not kidding like maybe 30 hours of
presentation
and audio and discussion storytelling
i can't help but fall into some
storytelling mode
with an extra little psychological
pressure of you
repeating right well also a lot of
people
sadly today um
experience what i would call the
database experience so
in the database experience you learn a
line the grunfeld and you
go and you get all of these databases
games and
this this move has been sequenced 500
times and the result is 43.6
versus this move that was sequenced 400
times but the result is a little bit
higher
and it's sort of like you getting all of
these
moves but they're devoid of emotional
content
i want to put it like that you play
in your first u.s championship game and
you come out with your new weapon that
you've been really working on the french
defense
and you get crushed i mean just
absolutely obliterated destroyed which
year was this
no not me and that's you i'm just you
know i'm just saying in an example
and suddenly you know
all your enthusiasm like you have gone
for the rest of this is gone
now like wait wait a minute what
happened the engine
says no man you were doing okay you only
had a slight disadvantage it was
here were you where you fell off the
boat
no you're in pain you're in pain
and so these
moves that you know you're just devoid
of this emotional
content right like whereas i was raised
on a book like for example david
bronstein's
the struggle right and
in that book it's like you know david
explains that
in this type of the position of the
king's indian when you're white and you
play the move
f4 this is a
liberty that you know maybe temporarily
maybe on the temporary moment you play
f2f4
as white in the king's indian defense
because
it helps your rook on f1 you know
like hey man that rook gets in the game
but
the bishop on g7 after the move e5
takes f4 is roaring down an open
diagonal for the rest of the game
the e5 square
the rook on e8 targets the pawn on e4
and the way he describes the drawbacks
of the move
f4 is going to send a shiver up your
spine yeah yeah
yeah you're not playing ethel
so it's this idea that um
in this chessable course that it's one
thing to sit there and just
use the database yeah it's not enough
it's just not enough
yeah if there's not an emotional
connection that you
get when you're connecting to you know
an
opening you know you've got to go
through the gauntlet you've got it
you you've got to be tested in in the
fires of competition and i remember
john fedorowitz man he's playing in a
u.s junior championship
something goes wrong with his dragon
he kick drops his favorite dragon bug
on a flight of stairs like he hasn't
never
played the track i mean it hurts it
hurts
you know like you can't just be devoid
of like oh i should have played that
no it hurts so
this idea of you know
that's one of the things that i want to
say what i really do like about online
is the online competition when i was
growing up my biggest problem was
finding
an opponent nobody wanted to beat up a
13 year old and
certainly nobody wanted to lose to a 13
year old or a 15 year old or whatever
now you can play online 724
get your handle and whether you're you
like one minute or three minute or five
minutes
yeah you can you can compete and you get
to
you you get to try out those french
defenses and the dragons and things like
that
and so that's one of the reasons why i
think
today's generations of young players are
so
much stronger than i well i
really want to conquer here because
um for a while i didn't understand
why braunstein does the things that he
does or the way he teaches
and he would play some outrageously bad
opening to
to test uh the young players
and i would say as from this generation
what is he doing this is just bad right
what is the point of this move and i
realized
he's just curious to see what is your
decision-making
mechanism right he's just interested yes
of course if i play the main line of the
nightdorf
you'll know everything right but if i
play this terrible move against you what
are you going to do with my terrible
move
exactly well one of the things that you
you i'm not you dennis but the audience
you start to understand
but only when you become a really really
really good player
you start to realize that your opponents
have a comfort zone
they get into their particular tabia
positions
that they know inside and out they know
that they've got this fortress they can
draw it they can do this they can do
that
they're in their comfort zones so
somebody who comes along and plays an
absolutely stupid miserable moment
yeah a2 a3 and move six and uh
wait what now what are you gonna do you
know
the onus is on you you're no longer in
your comfort zone
well david was one of those and i want
to say it
very i want to use this word
accurately he was a provocateur
loved to provoke you
into attacking him or into seizing the
defensive to take some
material and then defend
and the moment that that happened that
this
provocation took
you out of your comfort zone yeah and
you didn't play as well
uh emanuel lasker world champion
emmanuel alaska was
also disparaged for
purposely playing poor moves to
encourage the opponent to get optimistic
yeah
you know like before a moment ago the
guy's defending really really well
resultantly he's going to make a draw
now he's got an advantage now he says
aha
i'm going to punish the world champion
now that i have an advantage
and overstepping so these guys
these by the way tigran and petrosians
of the world
were provocateurs they they tried
purposefully deliberately to get you out
of their your comfort zone
the world champion that didn't do that
was anatoly karpa
anatoly karpov was technically perfect
he just
he played always technically well the
positions
he wasn't there as black to try to win
all of his games as was bobby fischer
no he just played technically incredible
well and he wasn't the provocateur
of david bronstein or for that matter of
ben larson
uh but i guess petrossian was close to
that like he was i'm taking a bit of
risk i provoke you a little bit
oh yeah but i'm installing the karo khan
i'm stealing yeah
he had his his setups and his fortresses
and one of the things that tigran did
extraordinarily well better than
anybody else within a very confined
amount of space he arranged this piece
as well
like normally speaking if i'm playing an
amateur player
and i get a big spatial advantage
i just press and squeeze them off the
board that's it they're gone
they're just like they're you know like
an eraser they get rubbed out
tigran wasn't that guy he did get rubbed
out i mean he just kind of like
bend bend bend snap forward and he was
really really unique and remarkable um
now that i've introduced myself i really
want to do
give the audience a chance uh give them
the floor and
yeah let them ask away yeah though they
did have a question
about your immortal games like we know a
lot of immortal games from petrossia
but i'm curious like uh your immortal
game
yeah which great player kind of
influenced you i had many many many
influences so when we talk about uh
great games of my career yeah sure i
mean i played
a lot but for me my career defining game
was my game
in cigaleftia in 1989 against
gary kasparov it was actually just
an amazing amazing game and in my book
chess duels which was a book about just
all my games with the world chess
champions
that game went for like 20 pages it was
just like an amazing game so what
happened is
he plays a kings indian i play an
overbox system with bishop e2 which
very quickly transposes into a benoni
and i get one of the worst bononi
positions ever
[Laughter]
just think of like a really totally ugly
ugly
bononi position and i got it
now normally in such a situation i just
offered my opponent to draw
and i don't excuse myself in this case
it was a little bit difficult
right so so the first phase of the game
goes
really really really really badly and it
was the gma
tournament the grand masters association
it was the
sixth and final tournament and karpov
and kasparov with a real real dog fight
for first and second
so the games that i played with them in
chicago were really important by the way
i ended up
tying i believe karpov and kasparov tied
for first i ended up tying for
third with nigel short and
maybe maybe portis i'm not sure
anyway so the point was i play this game
the first
part of the game goes really bad but
this is a really important tournament
the gma
i mean so much was riding on the outcome
we were playing in sweden sweden wasn't
noted
for hosting really big prestigious event
and the swedes went out i mean
marvelous playing home marvelous
conditions and the swedish
tv with these big big big cameras
were focused on the board and stuff
gary kasparov and benoni has his knight
on e5
perfectly like pawn on g5 pawn on h4
that knight on e5 is omnipresent it
ain't getting
moved everything has gone his
way and he plays the move c5
c4 is black c5 c4 is black
it doesn't just play the move c4 like
play
gary takes the ball he
twists it i mean he twists it like a
screwdriver into the board like somehow
by twisting it like nine
times it's going to go into the depth of
the square
and become a stronger move with each
twist he does
that and kind of rubs a little salt into
it and bam
hits the clock and the the the
swedish television man is like zooming
in
one of the worst strategic moves ever
ever like on a scale of one to ten this
is like
a 12. this is epically bad i like a
bishop i had a dark square bishop buried
on g1 that was doing nothing
now it's coming along now you know in a
benoni with a pawn on a5 it goes
screeching down on that there of a
knight on e2 that was like immobile
there's a pawn on h4 black pawn on h4
black pawn on g5 a black pawn on c5
this knight on e2 is a [ __ ] it can't
do anything
c5 c4 opens up
the d4 square i have a rook on b1 which
with the move b3 means a weakness on b7
and
instantly my game goes from like very
bad like minus two i don't know
to like plus one and a half
right but it wasn't that my
my position went from such a change it
was
my emotion was
that move sucks it's one of the worst
moves
ever i'm going to win this game with
that thought in mind
i decided i needed to give gary a kiss
that i get up from the board
tiptoe around the board go
right on his cheek tip to back and sit
down
and think about what i'm gonna do
the only reason i didn't
was because of the tv camera they were
too intimidating
this is like hammers like ah
but it actually goes through in my mind
if i kiss my opponent
is this like against the fide rules for
disturbing your opponent
and you know behaving badly
and then i tell gary after the game you
know i was planning on giving you a kiss
except
he said i deserve it
but i think you know like it was epic so
it went through my mind
so then of course you know everything
starts going my way and i'm killing it
yeah
uh i have these
massive massive complications i can
sacrifice my queen for two minor pieces
and like a super super nice pass pawn
or i can sacrifice my queen for a minor
piece in a rook and a
super super nice past pawn and i get
myself into time trouble i end up
at a piece up and
no time and on my 40th move i play the
proverbial mistake that throws away
my advantage but it was one of those
games
where it was this incredibly emotional
rollercoaster ride where
the like gary just doesn't back down
he just comes and he just throws the
pieces going bang bang bang bang bang
and i'm like collecting them
and my king is trying to get to safety
and it was just
it ended up as a draw and we analyzed
the game for months afterwards on a
flight
from moscow we ended up analyzing the
game
uh so that game for me was like a career
game
um i played a match it was like this is
great
this is this is like this perfectly
encapsulates my career
there was a marvelous world championship
match in 1990
it was between gary kasparov and anatoly
karpov it was played in new york city
as well as lyon
during the second and half of the match
in lyon
there was another match the best of the
west
oh the best of the west so there was
who was the number three player in the
world yon timma he was the number three
player in the world the number one and
number two
are in lyon and vishy hadn't really
shown himself at that time as much as he
is we now know
but the best of the west match was
jan and i uh
jan took a lead in the match and i came
storming back
to win the match four and a half one and
a half
nobody noticed because there was a world
championship
oh god that got all the all the press
all the way
even the dutch you know writers uh
newspaper writers the hans rays of the
world they were in lyons
when are we going to get a book on that
map there was a book on that match
not written by me but there was a book
on the match and uh
who wrote that uh some dutch uh
i'm i'm not sure it may have john
vanderville maybe a bit
okay so like yeah i mean and you know
you ruined paquette at the time
he was the trainer for yon timon he was
a second
and in hilversum where the match took
place
they each year they used to sponsor a
match but
timon played with kasparov he played
with portish
played with michael tall he played with
yes or sarah
and all of those matches got great
coverage except for my match with him
the best of the west because of the
world championship
is hilarious and i won a game in
particular in that match a kind of an
ode to paul morphy where i made the same
exchange sacrifice as the opera game
for for for tempo reasons and stuff and
it was really
like fantastic match games i won some
really really really beautiful match
games
so that for me was really you know like
a kind of
high mark if you will i also had uh
this was like hilarious right so i was
on a flight
from hamburg i don't know to like
bristol
like some place in england not even
my mother's british so maybe i had some
reasons to go there i'm not really even
too sure
where we were landing anyway you know
getting sit down and trying to look the
guy next to me it's anatoly carpon
like in a random universe karpov is
sitting next to me on a flight
to the middle of england like this is
like crazy right
ridiculous so we we just non-stop
talking the whole time and we were
comparing notes on all kinds of
things really going back and forth and
i get on the topic of grand master
victories
in a row and
i explained to him that i
he explains to me that he won six grand
master
games in a row six and um
i said yeah i had seven
and i did it on three occasions he goes
yeah yeah but who were the seven grand
masters that you beat and i said well
anatoly you were one of them
oh okay okay you luvo
lavoie
and then we stopped each other with some
laughter
and said bobby fisher won 20
wow in a row if you
include his games from the inter zonal
not
include the 21 game for the pano forfeit
but then you go with the bent larson and
timing off wipeouts
won 21 grandmaster games in a row and
like we just kind of looked at each
other
and that is what we said like that's
insane like that
is just to do that
your willpower has to be on some
extreme setting just like
it is like it's unbelievable you can't
like i was watching shaq
mamidara shaq in the last round of the
bucharest
event in the last round he's plus three
and a draw essentially clinches him at
least a tie for first let's put it like
that
and he just goes as fast as you can go
into the draw never for a single second
does he think
you know i should win this game go plus
four include grease my rating
show my world championship power and
that was an exact moment when bobby
fischer would say yes now i have to win
because i'm in good form to begin with
i'm in really really good form i'm
playing
against an opponent mvl i don't care
that he's a good player
he's in bad form and i mean i'm in a
great shape
so i mean the contrast couldn't be more
stark
and yet for you know for
for shaq he made the right decision by
his understanding of chess and 90
of the chess world agrees with him you
got to be on this extreme
like i don't even use the term fighter
are you some kind of ferocious
in a tasmanian devil
to play for a win in that situation
that's bobby yeah so i did want to come
back to uh your game with casper
as you said casper was sacrificing pawns
left and right
left and right exactly oh thank you i'll
take this something like that
right please more of that or anything
else you like
and i was wondering because
you worked with court schneider and i
wonder if
you were a disciple of korchnoy or you
yourself
already had this attitude of i'm gonna
take that pawn whatever happens happens
or was that rubbing off from him a
little bit oh there was definitely i
learned a great deal from victor my
propensity to be a pawn grabber didn't
completely come from victor but i think
in many ways he and i had a very similar
attitude of being provocateurs
walking on hot coals for a material
advantage we
had a great deal of
confidence in our own defensive
abilities so
grab the loot drag our opponents to
their ultimate
death yes that so that was we had that
in common
before we met
what we also had in common
was this i i want to say
love but i also want to use the word
respect
we both had this great love and this
great respect
for the game of chess it was like
this was something special it has a
history
you know we have to respect the game we
have to be
truthful to ourselves in the game we do
we
we we we have to
play properly so it wasn't like you know
i'll just do anything
i can and grab material just for the
sake of
no no no you have to also play properly
and also respect your opponent that
that they also have put themselves
through
the training and the thousands of hours
and the hard work to become a great
player so respect them
so we had this love of chess but also
this respect
and that went really really far there
was this like funny clip
i saw in a trailer a movie recently
it was like chris rock you know the guy
super muscle bound guy and there's this
comedian i think kevin hart is his name
and you're going to a class reunion and
there's the rocky look yeah he looks
like mr olympus and there's and
you know he comes up to
hey how are you doing you know it's
great to see you 20 years you have a
change
man i love you who are you
he tells the rock tells him who he is
and he says
my god what's your secret you look like
hercules
oh for the last 20 years i spent six
hours in the gym working out
every day oh that's
that that'll do it
and i always wondered about people who
said
you know like we've got we made this
mystery kind of thing like oh that chess
grandmaster
guy i mean he was born a grand master
no no no
no no anatoly karpov
this one-a-thon anand may have been the
two most gifted players
talented players i've ever met in my
life
and they worked incredibly hard
if those weren't the two most gifted
players then
gary was like a third and that guy
worked like a demon
i mean he worked when you know like look
at
his interviews when he talks about his
early matches he played five matches
with
karpov but his first match he trained
for
like eight hours a day for six months
solid
for one match of course that match
lasted 48 games it
never ended
have a great story about that match my
friend jonathan tisdale
he went to moscow to be the like
ap maybe it was the reuters reporter so
he was there for
six months he said yes sir at the end of
that match
i learned russian i lost my girlfriend
and got kicked out of the apartment i
was renting
it was pretty epic world championship
match
yeah that kind of reminds me of the fact
that um
so you had that uh book 60
remember yeah
chewing my way my my book yeah was
probably a colleague of this dolls
andres adorian's book he made a
hungarian book
on all of these kasparov matches and
that's the one i
chewed up like it's torn apart
every page turned around what happened
there
and it's just fascinating like um
because andrea sajorian was the trainer
to gary kasparov and a clash of
intellects a clash of styles and at a
certain moment
they parted and maybe andres
wasn't exactly happy with the way that
gary treated him
upon their departure and so he kind of
vented
yeah i think was it kevarde
what was the name of the book so it is
in hungarian
it's on kasparov in black and white okay
but it was actually like i read the
hungarian version
i don't even think there is any other
versions out there
um he's he is to having an honest take
but it's not at all um negative
right um but he says what he has to
endure
in those soviet times and he was
kind of like masquerading as tisdale's
colleague not exactly this doll
but a journalist but in reality he was
helping
kasparov okay so he goes to
moscow as some journalist he gets a
credential
for being hungarian
but it was just a masquerade he was
actually yeah
he was actually working uh uh secretly
for gary yeah and
he was like there was a back and forth
going on there that
are you really doing the journalists or
can i say
yesterday yeah and it's very fascinating
because he does talk about
what you see from badayef books of the
psychological states that they're in
and uh it was fascinating to me how he
describes
uh the lethargy when things are going
really bad for team kasparov
and when they're deciding no more
terrash or mortar or
grunfeld now right and
honestly apart from that barraev book i
barely had a book that described
human-ish emotions
yeah yeah and i think that that's a
a really important thing again this
emotional content in books like
i was really drawn to writers like david
monstein michael tall
ben larson because it wasn't just good
move bad move good move bad move oh i
should play here
i didn't like the outcome it was sort of
like okay this
this move is going to cost me ten
thousand dollars in my rent money
if it doesn't work out a lot of people
can relate to that right
so i like the stories behind the books
but
you know the really sad part for me
dennis is like
here in the united states maybe in
hungary i hope it was easier for you
it was very hard to get chess books like
literally you know there was the fred
reinfelds and the irv
and sure navs and if by luck you've
managed to find you know the two volume
series by alexander alekhine
or the series by paul cares
or you know my best games by paudinik or
smislov
if you could get those you know my best
games collections
they were marvelous marvelous marvelous
books with devoid completely of
emotional content
it was sort of like in this game i
decided to play the dutch
yeah yeah that's terrible
and and in these variations
in the dutch felt like bishop e7 i mean
that was the maximum amount of verbiage
and everything else was just moves and
moves and moves and moves
so a book like andres adorions where
you know he's really trying to share
you know his ups and his nouns and his
you know
how he feels and things like that that
those are really really rare books they
just
didn't come along just on that note i
just want to tell you one story
this is like a marvel story and i really
do want you guys to ask me questions
okay
so just tell you this one quick story
it's a match tigran petrossian versus
victor korchanoi and these two guys
hated each other's guts i mean
oh that i mean the tension between them
was palpable
no handshakes nothing draw offers went
through the arbiter harry golem deck
and those days they had a germans and
there was two germans that michael steen
and i
uh victor's trainer myself uh were
working on and one victor was worse but
we thought
we hoped he could draw on the other he
thought he was winning
okay victor thought he was winning he
had a queen
as white for two very good bishops
and a protected past pawn on c3
no no no no no no his opponent petrosian
had ample compensation
ample compensation he was better was
victor but
by no means was he winning
so uh they took the petrossian took a
time out and we spent like
literally i'm not joking when i say this
24 hours to study this position and i
just put my heart and soul in this in
this position
and after some perfunctory moves they
got to this very key moment
and i said victor you have to play g4
g2 victor nearly bit my head off
don't you understand anything about
chances
not happening nothing nothing no way g4
forget about it don
just don't waste your time we analyzed
all these other variations
kept coming to a draw
okay please play g4
rook c8 bang bang bang bang bang bang
you lose
okay h6 best move bravo h4
another move bang bang bang bang bang
you lose and this went on until he went
right down he exhausted all my analysis
came to the end and it was a draw it's a
draw with correct play
says you see you're you're your stupid
move g4 draws
like yeah but he he has to duck and bob
and weave and avoid all of these
traps along the way it's a good try
it's the best try
we go to the tournament playing hall the
first game they
they play a few moves and petrossian
offers a draw that's great
done draw then the second adjournment
there's a 30-minute pause in between i'm
at the backstage with victor
in his dressing room if you will you're
going to play g4
yes or no i leave
i go in the dark and theater so there i
am in the darkened theater
they play the moves they reach the
position and instantly and i mean
instantly the guy goes g4
corchanoid plays so there i am
in this darkened theater which was very
crowded by the way i want to
jump out of my seat and go yeah baby
played my move that's my move everybody
hello
you know just it's over here you know
give me some love
and i sit back down and then i'm just
kicking it i'm so happy with myself i
just can't believe
i'm happy with her and petrosian's
making all kinds of faces and petrosian
writes down a move
and five minutes goes by he changes uh
he writes down another move and this
goes on
for well beyond 20 25 minutes
way beyond and
during these 25 minutes something
incredible happened to me
that will never ever happen to another
grand master
ever what happened exactly what happened
can you guess what happened to me well
i'm about to tell you what happened to
me
what happened to me was
the enmity the animosity that these two
guys had for each other
was visceral i mean i'm talking
real hatred and then i started thinking
what if the move g4 had a flaw
what if victor played a move he
absolutely despised
on-site that i convinced him to play
and his most hated rival
defeated him beat him
put him behind in the match
i have to commit supuku for the honor
of the family right nothing less
we didn't have chess engines we couldn't
double check
and say yes yes yes g4 is a top computer
move maybe there is another line
no so i sat there mortified
after these 10 minutes i couldn't
breathe
petrosian played the very first move
that
korchnoy did against me in our analysis
rook c8
victor went bang bang bang bang bang
crushed him
and won the game brilliant
i went outside
you know like deep breaths relieved and
i stood by the car
as victor comes down the town hall steps
with this
boisterous crowd of cheer cheering
people
who are singing something in german i
don't know what it is
but they won't let him escape they're
literally rocking him back and forth
and he gets closer and closer and he's
wearing an overcoat and he's got the
fedora the special kind of hat
similar to yours and i'm holding open
the door
and of course goes to go in the car
when he comes out cause i i'm wearing
the cheshire
cat's kind of smile he says shut up
just shut up get in the car we all went
and celebrated
that was a different time a different
era and chess
and capturing that era in a book in a
podcast
and trying to explain to some 12 14 16
year old who was
raised on computers and smart phones
yeah
you know what it was like to take risks
and
come up with novel ideas it was like
like
no connection so uh there was a question
police from
the chat and um they were obviously
asking about
your relationship and working
relationship with court schnoy
i do want to add the first part though
you had a game
before you actually built a relationship
like a human relationship with him
what went through your brain while
preparing against
him because it must have been different
right oh well for sure
not well i mean in those days when i
played uh victor that was
the first game that we had was in 1980
in vikanze
and he was the new number two player in
the world but in those days they're
well with bobby fischer absent you know
and gary kasparov was still a junior uh
karpov and korchnoy vied in 1974
in the candidate's finals they played 24
games and victor lost 3-2
karpov became the challenger and won the
world championship by forfeit
so that game was basically for the world
championship
then in 1978 in
baguio city in the philippines
it was six to five in 1980
again victor is still so strong he's the
number two player in the world that he
would eventually win the candidates
thanks to my help and carry him to his
1981
world championship match in murano which
which karpov
emphatically won victor was in in
terrible form but the point was was that
victor was number two player in the
world
i i had no idea that post tournament he
was going to invite me to be a second
i'm just like
i mean an awesome guy you know like to
begin with
and i really could not prepare
because what had happened is i had come
from hastings
where anybody who's ever played in
hastings carried with them a cold
back home so i'm like you know i'm like
my nose
head is stuffed i'm i'm swallowing
aspirin
steam steam bass and uh
my preparation was you know just trying
to get to the board without
embarrassing myself by blowing all over
the place
as luck would have it and i mean to
emphasize this
victor did me the biggest solid ever
there was one opening i mean one opening
one specific
variation i knew inside out backwards
forwards
left to right he walked right into it
i mean it couldn't have been any better
and victor i mean i have
mercilessly killed dozens
of players in swiss tournaments
in this position dozens
the guy's gone he's toast i don't care
if he's number two player in the world a
world champion or future world champion
he's toast
that you can't play this position yeah
victor goes
into a 45 minute thing and comes up with
a concept
that i never even considered
having spent hundreds of hours on this
particular position
it was extraordinary i was just like
flabbergasted that somebody
how inventive how creative he was to
find
and he almost escaped he almost escaped
that 45 minutes proved costly he got
into severe time pressure
later in the game i went bang bang bang
bang and i won
but you know i want to emphasize that
playing against
victor was wasn't a challenge
it was an honor yeah it was just like
holy smokes i get to play viktor
korchnoy
i mean please oh please don't embarrass
myself
let me play a good game let him win a
good game let me make a draw let me win
a good game
but i just want to play a good game i
just don't and it turned out that
i played like one of the best games of
my life
and that particular tournament which was
really
really amazing something else that will
never ever
ever ever happen again to any other
grand master
happened to me in that tournament i
scored 10 and a half out of 13. it was
by gonza it was the masters group it's
one of the best scores
you could get the grand master norm was
something like seven and a half so i was
like three points above the grand master
very nice
yeah somewhere around round
round nine top grand master from iceland
grand manchester
sigur johnson resigned the game
and i clinched my third and final grand
master norm
nice exactly at the moment
there was a gong
pa system public announcement
comes on please everybody please
please please stop your clocks please
everybody just stop your clock stop for
your clocks
like what the hell is that right right
in the middle of the round you know
like this is crazy coach noise playing
timmons playing all of these top guys
are playing
please please everybody stop your clocks
two ladies come on stage with these
silver trays
bottles of champagne
and flutes of champagne for
all of the people on stage please
everybody please could you please stand
uh we would like to salute grand
master yasser sarwan who
thanks to his victory today has made his
third and final they don't call it norm
they called it ball
they've made his third and final ball
and we'll be
made a grand master at the next congress
please everybody give a salute
everybody on stage victor courtney the
middle of the game please i have a
champagne
can you imagine this is crazy right
what's even crazier one of the amateur
players in the lower section
his opponent had fiddled and made a
touch move
and didn't make the move with the touch
piece
that's outrageous outrageous that
man got up and went to the chief arbiter
to complain about the bad behavior of
his opponent not making
it making the touch move and he happened
to be on stage when
he got a glass of champagne it happened
to be complaining about
that guy was my future father-in-law wow
john nagle and i said well ever since we
met
you've been on my account
and i i married his daughter uh yvette
is my wife wow
that's just fantastic and i'm i'm kind
of like interested in the fact that
korchner is known to be not so gracious
when he loses
like how did he act when he lost against
you
how that's turned into sort of
friendship kind of exactly
so i really you dennis you're absolutely
right like
the worst thing the worst the absolute
worst thing that could happen to a
grandmaster so lose the game
yeah that's not the worst thing there's
one thing even worse than that
and that's losing to a junior player
okay victor was a very very strong
believer in beating them while they were
young
because the young grow up to be monsters
so
you better get a plus score against them
now
because it's going to be harder later so
there i was
i just beat victor korchnoy and i'm this
junior and victor's just so
disgusted he's like signs of score she
he wants to tear away
go to his room and like tear the
furniture out of the room he's
furious and i with my popcorn smile said
mr korchner would you like to analyze me
i'm sorry yeah exactly so
i'll tell you exactly what was going
through victor's mind so like victor's
like
he's thinking he's thinking if he goes
back to his room
he may seriously damage the room
certainly he's going to damage his hand
from hitting the wall there's no
question about that
he'll be upset instead he can
play the role of a masochist and torture
himself
more we could analyze together
and then he would learn how really
incredibly stupid he was and
how could he have lost to this [ __ ]
idiot junior player
so is a bit of a masochistic streak as
well as a
sadistic street in every chess player
you have to have
those two things okay
let's analyze
so victor comes and he gets to his
terrible position and he where he played
this incredible move bishop c5
i should have played the normal move
bang bang bang bang you lose
that was what i was afraid of you remind
me you reminded me yeah
i saw this variation that's why i didn't
play it
okay well later in the game
i should have played this no boom boom
boom
you lose now victor
this happens like five times in a row
like where the alternative
the alternative he had would have
accelerated
his defeat no mr corchanoy
it was like it moved 26 when you played
this move
v8 this was your best chance you had to
go into this
much worse ending because what you
played ended up
here victor walked out of the room
wondering what the hell just happened
like he didn't understand he genuinely
didn't understand
that my familiarity was so
great for that particular position
that it went into end game positions
like my understanding
if you had given me any other titles
i would have been the idiotic [ __ ]
like how dare i meet him right
but that just happened to be my position
so victor was like kind of a he went out
and had a nice dinner
as he told me later that he would never
have gone out for dinner
he didn't deserve dinner then he
deserved
then he would come to me during the
gaming
look the game tim what do you think who
stands better
and i would tell them and
he he was testing me to be
a a trainer to him and i didn't know
that of course
of course i just hey yeah man that's a
cool move look at that movie
later after the tournament was over he
said
yes sir i'd like to ask you to be my
trainer my second and what was going
through my mind exactly at that moment
exactly that moment is
could i afford it how much do i have to
pay
victor to train with him
i'm making the mental calculations can i
afford it
and i didn't answer and victor
misunderstood my silence and he said oh
oh yeah well i i pay all your travel
your hotel costs
your meals and 500 swiss francs
a week
it finally registers on me
that he's going to pay me to work
and train with him
my hand came out of nowhere man oh
i was so delighted you know the story of
course with victor
the first night at his home you know
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah you gotta shoot
the guy in the room
that was me
it was good what are the questions
yes so um the other question
um it was sort of a statement they
really
loved your book winning strategies
thank you one of their favorites and
they think it's one of the best
thank you and talking about books yeah
so there is
one part that is my question and i do
want to touch upon that book in front of
you
king king hot off the press everybody
but before we do i do want to
just talk a little bit about this
discrepancy it's not a real discrepancy
but it kind of
irked me um you have
your book on fisher you've got the no
regrets
yeah the fisher book you've got the
other book and i was wondering
yeah um five crowns that was my first
book um
yeah so i'm mostly referring to the
books
that you were reading as coming up as a
player right
and none of them really says oh play the
english opening
that's the one you should be playing so
i'm wondering
you read all these books from fisher and
suddenly you play the
english how did that came from oh that
that that
was really easy okay so essentially
there are two main openings for
white e2 e4 or e4
and d2 d4 and these are two enormous
branches in fact there are volumes of
the encyclopedia chess
opening that are devoted to e4 games
and to d4 games and quite frankly the
amount of work
that it's required to play e4
was greater than anything i could do i
mean
at the time i kind of had a
i'm not going to say an agreement but
very very
clear understanding from my parents
which was very simple yes sir
you we will support you playing chess
we'll support you
going to these weekend events where
sometimes you have to leave school on a
friday or
your skip a monday we're going to
support you
with your entry fees and
your purchase of books we're going to do
all of that
but you are going to score very very
well on your academic test you are going
to
go to the university we've got this
education fund for you
this is happening so if chess
interferes at all with your schoolwork
you can
kiss it goodbye there will be no chats
so my schoolwork as i i
briefly mentioned i did graduate a year
early which required me to take
summer courses and get these extra
credits
in school i went to garfield high school
of public high school
in seattle washington and
you know i was taking the hardest
courses i could
because it was necessary to get college
credits
for my high school yeah
and whatever garfield offered in terms
of college credits that i could use at
the university
man i went for them and they were pretty
they're happy yeah they were very
demanding especially the chemistry
classes anyway the bottom line is
i actually had to work hard at school
and i
was like a four point i was like uh yeah
i had a good uh i had
i was a good student good grades yeah
for a very specific reason i wanted to
make my parents happy which made me able
to say yeah i'll play in that
event and in fact one one year one
one event i couldn't and i remember to
this day and i it really was very sad it
was a vancouver open
1975 vancouver british columbia the open
friends and i drove from seattle across
the border of canada
to bc spent the night
and drove back at that tournament i
watched
the grand master paul cares like a hawk
from the outside and i watched how he
moved the pieces in a very gentlemanly
manner
and always put the piece directly on the
center of the square
and i went home to practice because
even if i couldn't make moves that were
as good as paul's
i could play them in the same manner
and not to disturb the opponent at all
i wanted to play in the tournament i
couldn't because it was one of those
nine-day events where it was one game a
day blah blah blah
two weekends i'd have to miss too much
of schoolwork or something like that
so i had to put in a lot of time on the
school work
then it was just playing chess i mean
the the
these uh tournaments um
you know five rounds yeah weekends and
what have you i
couldn't spend a thousand hours
analyzing one e4
i couldn't spend a thousand hours
analyzing one d4
i had to play a side variation and the
english was a marvelous side variation
because
the transpositions if we want to
transpose it to grunfeld
i could i could choose it if we wanted
to transpose into a king's indian i
could
choose the transposition i played the
english
to transpose to positions that i wanted
to play and i played the english also to
keep the english
flavor like what is the very floor
mckenna's variation
c4 knight f6 knight c3 e6 and an e4
that's a very very english position you
don't get that
out of anything else and so i
did my best to specialize in those
things that's what victor fell for by
the way that was that floor mckenna's
variation so that was why the english
became
my repertoire part of my and
unfortunately i
i really mean to say this and it's a
very very sad thing that i have to say
is when i was playing chess
professionally
i really wasn't in the sense
that chess didn't support professional
grand masters from the west bent larson
you think to yourself oh ben larson is a
great professor big big big big player
big bet
no no no no no most of his income came
from his columns he wrote for newspapers
he wrote books
because the prize monies were so bad i
remember
very very vividly he he lost a
uh semi-final against boris baskey
candidates and he got 250 swedish crowns
which is like a hundred bucks
and it was like a three-week match
adjournments
all kinds of costs and that was his
prize
like what yeah so it was like these
soviet grandmasters
were professionals yeah they had
government support state support
uh you think of sami rushevsky really
one of the great american giants of
chess
no no no sammy was a cpa
a certified public accountant his
professional
job was accounting reuben fine another
great american player world's top 10
player
he gave up chad to become
a psychiatrist and so forth and so on
i'm just saying that bobby fischer
tried desperately hard to be a
professional player
and he was very often skirting on the
edges of the destitution so there are a
couple of more things that
i want to so we had a question
and then i'd like to talk about that
book in front of you but before that
there was a question
asked by chet asking
if you'd see someone do commentary
from the crop who you're seeing in the
chess world who would it be
the the commentators yeah yeah yeah well
actually i i'm very very uh
pleased to say that i think there's some
really marvelous presenters
in the world of chess a lot of times
chess is a solitary game
it really doesn't lend itself over
easily
to being a presenter
on the magnus carlson tour yeah i was
really
i was stunned i worked with tanya sachet
and peter peter yeah
i couldn't believe what a great
commentator peter laico was i was just
amazed peter svidler's remarkable but i
i have to say that for peter fiddler
he's talking to
me unfortunately he's not talking for an
audience he's not trying
he's just blitzing through tons of
variations
and i'm just sitting there and awk
well done well done well done i really
enjoyed the streamers i think for
example
i mean it's not everybody's taste maybe
you're an acquired taste
i think ben feingold's hilarious i
really enjoy it
eric hanson for me the chess bros i'm
just like
are you just thinking about it makes me
laugh
uh we're really really blessed
amazingly in the world of chess
which is really really sad and it's been
that way from
my early days it's really a
male dominated sport i mean literally
at the american chess service in seattle
the chess club that i was raised up in
seattle
there was no women players not a single
one not a single member
now i look at the presenters the
streamers whether it be jennifer shahady
alexandra brothers anna rudolph tanya
they're wonderful they're wonderful i
love
jovi ivanka it was really funny jovi
comes in
to studio a here in saint louis and
she's
immaculate she's well dressed she's
preempted
she's got her little script she's got it
all
all set she's going welcome everybody
she's got this wonderful british accent
you know welcome everybody
so now there's a little anyway it
doesn't matter she's going to do a
presentation
and uh and my co-host
yasser sarwan uh yes sir uh thank you
for being with us uh she's expecting me
to say something like
yes thank you jovi it's uh nice to be
with you too instead i say something to
the effective like
jovi yesterday you were wonderful
i have three words for you fabulous
freezer right so she's thinking about
these three words
fabulous in her script
she got around completely off it was
wonderful and
i just wanted to say that in the world
of chess
what's really remarkable is we do have
some really great presenters
and all of the names that i just said i
would be
very very happy to work with jennifer
shahady of course has been
my right arm a lot of people
yeah a lot of people don't know this but
uh a very close friends were their
father
iron mike because he did the iron mic
triathlon iron mike shahadi he's a
master from philadelphia pennsylvania
and
many time champion of pennsylvania and
we go way back
and one time i was doing a video series
pro-chess
in philadelphia and i babysat
greg shahadi oh the older brother of jen
that's why he doesn't play the
scandinavia very good
i'm sure there was a connection but okay
yeah so
it's remarkable for me when i think that
i would end up doing commentaries
alongside jennifer it's really really
nice
um in
truth i haven't had a bad experience
except for one except for one okay
we'll keep we'll we'll keep that secret
no i won't know
what you want to share oh yeah oh
because it was hilarious
all right so what happened
was there as my gun say i'm doing my
commentary
and there's a game between
yo baba who's crushing
ivan chuck crushing uber they're just
crushing it
and slowly slowly yvonne check somehow
slipping and sliding
you know yoba is losing his grip and
losing his grip and finally they get
into a rook ending
it's a draw so what a great
save by yvonne
then yobava makes the offer of a trade
of rooks to go into a king and pawn end
game
which is like really really really
shocking
because that king on pawn end game you
could be burning your bridges you could
be losing
he's slightly better in the rook ending
to go into a king and pawn end game
well is there a win so i'm sitting there
trying to figure out the win
for jerovah why else would he go into
this king pawn in game
when ivan chuck has captured the rook
and yobava resigned
well that's stupid yeah you don't resign
did he pray did he lose on time no no he
has plenty of time
he resigned no you recapture the rook
and the guy will show you why he's going
to beat you
so i'm trying to figure out first of all
why you resign and
where is the wind and n walks the seal
vessel ivancia chuck meister come and
sit down
how is that boomer boy how you doing how
are you feeling good everybody good
won't you show the people the game
and he's like a dolphin
i mean he's just oh everything
meticulous
it flows it flows and flows
and thank you goodbye not for me
not for me of course not for me vasil
but for the audience
only that for the glorious audience
could you please explain to them why
your opponent resigned
talk talk talk talk talk talk 12 moves
bridesmaids too far apart
uh white loses oh thank you thank you
any good grandmaster would found it
instantly
any good grandmaster so he leaves
i exit for the audience just a second i
got to take the sword out of my belly
we're going to be on a break
my dear friend ivan sakala is
in stitches he's laughing he's watching
the broadcast from his
apartment in the vikings 8 down the road
he's laughing laughing
laughing the next day he goes to
breakfast
a little cheese a little them a little
bread
and grandmaster ivan sarah she was like
a
2700 grandmaster comes
next to yvonne and evan
why did job of a resign yesterday
and he goes the whole line
any good grandmaster would come out
so it had a ripple looks like right
there
in the world of chess
you know sometimes being a commentary
you know like it's a tricky job it's a
dirty job
it's a dirty job thank you
thank you so much and before we go of
course tell me
okay what the king okay
so i have a very dear friend bruce
harper bruce
uh he lives up in british columbia
uh they were like these canadian raiders
that used to come down
peter biases duncan suttles brewfo for
bruce harper
robert zuke jonathan berry uh seth
taylor
uh oh uh nigel fullbrook uh mad dog
nigel fulbrook they'd all come down and
they'd raid the south they raid us in
seattle
and in portland and i became very close
friends
of bruce bruce went on to he had a very
strange relationship
he became a prosecutor for the crown an
attorney
for the crown of british columbia
whereas his wife robin
became a defense attorney
the power couple that clashes anyway
bruce is a wonderful writer he's
about a 23 2400 master together
we we created best chess
sarah one chest yeah he was the inventor
alongside
of me with the hawks and elephants
ages ago i don't even want to say how
long ago because it's a bit embarrassing
i'm
gonna guess seven years ago he said yes
sir i've got this great idea for a
project
king walks where a player voluntarily
walks
their king across the board for a very
specific strategic purpose so for
example your king might be on the king
side
and you might want to launch a pawn
attack g4
h4 g5 it's called english attack yeah
but your king's there so you would
escort your king and tuck it away over
the queen side so you could go
and there's some really really marvelous
games unfortunately in my
case i played a lot of game vlogs
not all of them were very very
successful
and you know there are there's suicide
margins yeah and we had so much fun
writing the book we forgot
that we would ever give it
yeah exactly exactly and it's a real
nice comp
compilation of um
lots of uh king walks very instructive
king walks
exactly and i mean a lot of people
forget
you you remember the nigel short game
but a lot of people forget the nigel
short king walk in his game with
alexander believsky
in that game he was playing in lonar as
he has much better position as king
i think goes somewhere from say g2 to c6
where
believsky gives him checkmate wow
like it's not like he goes king c6
anticipating some reaction and his
opponent goes mate
so while he's celebrated for the tim
on march people forget the suicide march
and there's some really really funny
things
so literally
with a pandemic raging uh bruce is like
yes you're not going to believe this but
i think after seven years we finished
the book
it's like what really i mean it finally
you know it finally happened
yeah yeah so somehow during the pandemic
and we got
together with our friend hannan and
russell russell enterprises
because unfortunately the really sad
truth is
that book publishers today
it's openings man they don't want to
they don't
want this they don't want any memorable
games they don't
want you know the david bronstein's you
know
theory and practice you know tournament
books i mean to say they don't want the
book collection so this is a collection
of king wonks and hannan said sure let's
let's have some fun with it because he
actually laughed and
fell in love with the book too so that's
how it got published it's a great book
and i do invite everyone to get it
thank you thank you and thank you by the
way a big thing
thanks to all the supporters uh and
again
i think it was the queen's gambit uh
impact the effect that my books in
particular
just had an enormous year because of so
many people discovered chess through the
queen's gambit
and they started and my chessable
courses
so it's the weirdest thing that during
the pandemic
that chess yeah just like skyrocketed
yeah and as an author i'm like really
really grateful so big
thank you for all of the people and
regarding the no regrets yeah i think
eventually we'll have to get it
reprinted
well i want to thank you for being here
and
my pleasure it was just an amazing time
thank you for all the stories
especially the gorge so thank you so
much everyone for joining us
and see you next time bye bye
cool
this has been a presentation of the st
louis chess club